five industry i would be pursuing that
are coming up all things that are
associated with cryptos nfts d5 web 3.0
you learn this is a big favorite of mine
and that's because i think the formal
education has failed many of us is an
antiquated system that is built on
general knowledge rather than specific
knowledge and right now people want
specific skills that they can use in the
marketplace to make more money if you
have a niche skill the e-learning
marketplace is something that i would be
looking at remote living more people are
moving out of cities they're moving to
have more space they're having at-home
offices this thing that i'm recording on
is a mobile studio if you're a
photographer build mobile studios tons
of people want to be able to travel they
want to have studios from home tons and
tons of business to be had there you
don't even have to market there's so
much demand for this type of stuff
warehousing logistics there is more need
for shipping and stuff to be stored now
than ever before the demand for people
to be lazy is very very high anything
that works in a trend of delivering
something to someone faster with the
least amount of effort they just click
something and it shows up those are
things that i would be investing in
because i believe that they will be the
things that outperform the marketplace's